[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire au programme aujourd'hui le
21e siècle et une 18e je reçois en effet
le philosophe eric sadin pour son essai
faire sécession une politique de nous
mêmes ou comment s'opposer aux
impératifs catégoriques de notre époque
et l'historienne cécile berly pour la
légèreté et le graver une histoire du
xviiie en tableau et on commence tout de
suite par les images que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque la
vôtre cécile
c'est celle ci c'est belmondo c'est
l'hommage national à belmondo
je trouvais pour mois de septembre dans
une période qui était d'un point de vue
sanitaire et politique bien lourde
bien sûr on avait beaucoup de chagrin
mais il y avait aussi malgré tout une
forme de légèreté c'est là qu'on a re
découvert un grand artiste sa
filmographie c'est un chagrin qui
n'était pas si triste que ça en fait et
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un moment de
communion nationale
du moins une grande partie de nos
concitoyens je trouve que c'est un
moment qui nous a fait presque du bien
en fait le belmondo fait du bien le voir
ça fait du bien même quand il disparaît
ou vous même quand il disparaît et la
vôtre eric sadin c'est celle ci
alors qui est ce
c'est l'image de quelqu'un qui
s'adonnent à la permaculture
parce que je crois que là il ya un
puissant signe de l'époque
cette envie de
toujours plus massive somme toute
récente qu'on peut dater de mon sens du
milieu des années 2010 2015
de s'investir dans des pratiques
supposant des relations plus équitables
entre autres les êtres dans le cadre de
l'activité et plus respectueuse du
milieu ce au moment où dans le quotidien
notamment dans le cas du travail on est
toujours plus confrontée la plupart sont
confrontés à des situations
contraintes souvent dégradantes parfois
avilissante et et conduisant à
l'impression de l'inutilité de soi alors
je crois que le gars de cette situation
c'est d'eux que là c'est à la
collectivité à la société de donner des
moyens à ce que c'est ses aspirations
pour autre chose puisse se prendre corps
et que ça se relève pas que des
initiatives individuelles etc et c'est
là un des enjeux majeurs de mon livre de
2 comment se donner les moyens de donner
corps et de soutenir toutes les
aspirations pour autre chose et bien
commençons
[Musique]
eric sadin vous êtes l'auteur entre
autres de la vie algorithmique critique
de la raison numérique et de l'air de
l'individu tyran vous publiez à présent
faire sécession une politique de nous
mêmes à l'échappée face à une industrie
d'un nouveau genre diot visées
hégémoniques il est vain dites vous de
tout attendre d'un éventuel retour de
l'état providence ou du souverainisme
monétaire on se trompe de combat votre
avis quand on est là tous a invoqué la
figure du général de gaulle elle est
très à la mode en ce moment et pas
seulement parce que c'est l'anniversaire
de sa mort et
de gaulle contre google et facebook
c'est perdu d'avancé
c'est que surtout que nous visons nous
vivons une situation paradoxale c'est à
dire que je pense que jamais à la fois
nous éprouvons un sentiment de
saturation
le père d'adhésion à l'égard d'un ordre
politique
institutionnel économique
que j'avais analysé dans mon livre
précédent maire de ladiville tyran
agréger les âges des technologies
numériques que chacun s'en remet à sa
propre parole avec des effets des
séparations entre les êtres de repli sur
soi et en même temps jamais autant
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des envies je l'
ai dit à l'instant pour pour pour autre
chose pour des vies qu'ils soient plus
épanouissante plus vertueuses qui ne
laisse pas la biosphère qui antique qui
font appel à notre créativité a des
liens d'entr'aide et 7 cette situation
que ce qui expose une sorte de tension
ce qu'on n'arrive pas à la dénouer cette
saturation et l'envi pour autre chose et
c'est et on en revient finalement à des
à des vieux réflexes c'est à dire que
cette campagne présidentielle qui
s'amorce d'une certaine façon confirme
c'est à dire à la fois on n'y croit plus
et en même temps on est dans des temps
des principes d'attentes démesurées
c'est à dire on veut encore croire
malgré tout notre désillusion malgré
tout les lendemains qui déchantent
lendemain ensuite à aux élections que
malgré tout est bien
le retour de l'état providence une
figure qui
renouerait avec un esprit qui ont été
celui des voilà de l'état protecteur
nous sauverait de tous nos maux or ce
que je crois c'est que ce qu'on a appris
c'est que il ne faut pas s'illusionner
sur ce que peuvent des institutions la
politique institutionnelle et qui lui
revient avant tout de s'assurer de sa
prérogative c'est dire la qualité des
services publics qui sont lambeaux
l'hôpital est en lambeaux l'école
publique est en lambeaux alors que nous
laissait espérer je ne sais trop quel
horizon démagogique expurgée de tous les
maux du pays je crois qu'il faut revenir
à des comme on dit aux recteurs des
fondamentaux que également vous vous le
dites dans votre livre je vois vos mains
il faut mobiliser nos propres forces se
prendre en main c'est sa succession
alors quand je parle de faire sécession
c'est pas du tout faire sécession à
l'égard de l'ordre comme un sévère
sécession à l'égard de nos réflexes nous
attendent des mesures et de nos
rancoeurs de nos rangs soit sinon et de
tenter de s'engager dans une sorte de
jeu presque en indivis dire de double
niveau c'est-à-dire peser pour que la
politique institutionnelle réponde à ses
prérogatives un
impôt équitable plus se soucier de la
qualité des services publics c'est un
enjeu majeur en démocratie en france un
canton qui ont été dégradées par souci
d'économie par an c'est toute une
idéologie de l'optimisation de tous les
secteurs de qui supposait des réductions
personnel enfin on a vu avec la crise du
coc vide tout ce que cela suppose et
notamment dans le par exemple à l'école
publique aussi des hôpitaux bondés et
puis la justice tout ça ce sont des
polices tout ça ce sont des services
publics déjà que ses services publics
que ces deux prérogatives de l'état est
bien ce cela ce pour cela ce soit cela
qu'ils soient engagés comme action
d'urgence aujourd'hui me nous revient
quantité de choses à nous tous c'est à
dire qu'il ne faut pas s'illusionner sur
la grande politique la politique
institutionnelle qui on le voit ne faut
pas s'illusionner non plus dit vous sur
sur nos libertés c'est à dire l'individu
armé d'aspar smartphones et d'un
bulletin de vote se croit libre vous
avez l'air de dire qu'il ne l'est pas cc
c'est pas qu'ils se croient temps libre
c'est le fait que d'abord ça leur envoie
quand même avec tous et les usages des
plateformes et d' usage de la parole
aussi à ça consolide l'idée de l'antre
l'auto entreprenariat de la vie hein
c'est à dire chacun s'en sortir avec ses
technologies on s'appuie sur elle et
puis aussi sur le fait de la de la
primauté de la parole la primauté du
verdun et on peut dire la halle à l'ère
des réseaux sociaux
au début des années 2010 aujourd'hui on
est dans l'ère des plateformes de
l'expressivité c'est à dire de notre
notre illusion de nous croire agissant
politiquement c'est de continuellement
faire part de nos opinions en scène le
fait est que ça ne produit rien donc la
question je me suis posée suite à mon
précédent livre la comédie du tyran
c'est comment nous rendre
individuellement et collectivement
davantage agissant et
et comment
qu'est ce que suppose la bonne
expression de notre condition politique
aujourd'hui et moi je crois qu'il faut
revenir à des choses très pragmatique je
pense par exemple aux discours quand
j'ai analysé l'évolution des
technologies numériques depuis une
quinzaine d'années je me suis rendu
compte que nous avons été bien trop
passif par exemple à l'égard des
discours qui façonnent la société et à
l'égard du mouvement dit pères expertise
à sion de la société je donne un exemple
j'ai à frédéric l'hôpital public du coup
quand même une dimension à laquelle nous
avons été confrontés depuis deux ans et
nous avons vu toutes les lacunes et bien
nous savons aujourd'hui par exemple que
une entreprise privée de conseil
capgemini
est allé donner des leçons à des
directeurs d'hôpitaux il ya des
personnels depuis deux pital en vue de
par exemple leur dire la cour des
comptes s'est penchée sur cela en 2018
et il ya eu des rapports de la cour des
comptes qui sont plus qu'éloquents en
vue de leur dire avec une sorte de
novlangue
qui
relève des cabinets de consulting qu'il
faut transformer l'hôpital en hôpital 2
allée de l'hôpital de stoke en hôpital
de flux comprenez toute une série de
neuf langues qui attise tiens qui s'est
immiscé aussi dans l'entreprise la
quantité de jargon d'expression qui
demis un peu le personal et qui ont fait
qu'ils n'ont pas pu s'opposer à des
mesures qui souvent les amoindrissent et
sur les gars ils ne pouvaient à l'égard
des cas ils ne pouvaient faire part de
leurs de leur assentiment de laure et je
pense que cela est aussi dû à une
idéologie qui a beaucoup infuser dans la
société depuis une quinzaine d'années
notamment relativement à l'expansion des
technologies numériques c'est l'idée que
la société c'est aussi ça a été aussi à
l'oeuvre avec des services publics par
exemple que notre société devait être à
terme toujours plus optimisée et
délivrer de tous les défauts et il ya eu
des vecteurs qui sur lesquelles on
pouvait s'appuyer et qui ont été ont été
présentés comme pouvant permettre cela
c'était un mouvement de dix paires
technologisation la société
et ça c'est ça a été due aussi à ce que
je nomme l'idéologie du futur c'est à
dire nous promettait toujours par par
des techniques par des méthodes par des
discours souvent en anglais qui
désiraient élevées signalées des
perspectives comme ça qui paraissait
presque presque relever de la magie bah
ça nous a démuni c'est à dire que là il
ya une il ya une des branches de ce qui
relève de notre condition politique
c'est à dire contre et des discours qui
façonnent la société ses discours là
qu'ils se sont imposées et qui ne répond
qu'à des intérêts privés et à une vision
du monde ce soit dans l'entreprise dans
les secteurs publics dans la quantité de
change la société c'est à nous de nous
organiser en vue de l'écrit de les
mettre en critique et faire valoir des
contres discours mais quand je quand je
parle de contrer discours ça veut dire
aussi faire valoir des témoignages des
contre expertises qui après nous raconte
comment ça se passe dans l'hôpital on
nous l'a passé raconté vous souvenez
frédéric comme par exemple emmanuel
macron aller visiter les hôpitaux il ya
deux trois ans les personnels étaient
dans la rue il en parler puis retour
devenait normal le lendemain ça passait
aux infos le luberon je peux pas dire
non plus que les citoyens français était
passionné par ce qui se passait dans
l'hôpital tant qu'ils ne sont pas
obligés d'y aller il n'éprouve pas une
curiosité
énorme pour ce qui s'y passe vous avez
l'air de dire que nous subissons
plusieurs juniors il ya cinq chaudières
décrire absolue aussi le jour des
machines absolue meyrals absolue est
aussi bien en tant que travailleur qu'en
tant que consommateur absolument c'est à
dire alors là il y aurait beaucoup à
dire je vais essayer d'être concis sur
ça le joug des machines de joux du
dispositif de système qui de plus en
plus
encadre des conduites jusqu'à
induire avec le monde la logistique
intégral qui est qui qui ne cesse de se
consolider du fait de notamment deux qui
étaient déjà en place mais du fait de la
crise de quoi vide existentiel le fait
de mener de plus en plus de nos actions
quotidiennes à distance par exemple
émergent
oui un monde à terme de la logistique
intégral dont amazon a pris les se situe
aux avant postes il y à des méthodes
de management qui sont à l'oeuvre qui
sont totalement indigne qui relèvent de
ce qu'on peut appeler un esclavagisme
moderne numérique qui va jusqu'à envoyer
des signaux aux manufacturiers qui leur
demande d'aller dans tel endroit
recherché tel produit il a déposé une
telle planète et à des cadences
infernales qui est qui est en général
entraîne très rapidement des troubles
musculo squelettiques ou d où d ou des
dépressions ou des arrêts du travail qui
est aussi qu'ils
induisent une surconsommation et des
conséquences écologiques très très très
conséquente et qui ne font absolument
pas à faire là il est aussi question de
notre condition politique en termes de
conscience de ça est ce que parce que là
c'est le back office de l'économie
numérique on ne le voit pas est ce que
dans quelle mesure ça fait part de notre
mobilisation je pense que plutôt de
continuellement nous soucier de nos
données personnelles sur notre petite
vie privée serait temps que la société
se mobilisent relativement à des enjeux
majeurs se serait pas compliqué il
suffirait d'être moins pressés c'est
parce qu'on est pressé le numérique à
encourager chez nous le fait qu'on veut
les choses qu'on dont on a envie on les
veut tout de suite le plus vite possible
on les veut le magasinier qui que vous
décrivez il était aux ordres a comme
comme celui qui prépare un hamburger
chez mcdo ou ailleurs il est à deux
ordres il est juste devant nous
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps en fin ou
du moins le livreur qui arrive et qu'on
engueule parce qu'il est en retard
absolument c'est à dire qu'on est
aujourd'hui on est livré en temps record
presque c'est presque en écho avec le
cric ou le toucher comme ça
immédiatement et
évidemment que tout ça du une sorte de
facilitation d'existence je pense que
nous sommes tous dans une schizophrénie
c'est à dire qui ne dénoncent pas amazon
qui met dénonce pas facebook sur
facebook c'est à dire là c'est
spéculaire c'est pas dans quelle logique
on est de dénoncer le capitalisme sur
facebook enfin il ya décembre qui dotent
mal son nom livreurs ou son chauffeur
union enfin au restaurant oui mais mais
vous savez là on parle d' amazon qui est
enfin amazon ou en tous les cas les
techniques qu'ils soient l'oeuvre dans
le dans la logistique dans les
techniques hyper sophistiqué un
expression aussi un cd techniques de
livraison à la plus grande vitesse mais
c'est à l'oeuvre dans tout le travail
aujourd'hui dans tout le monde du
travail le fait de deux par exemple le
télétravail
induits enfin l'extension subit du
télétravail suite au confinement induit
une comptine une quantification
sournoise des pratiques c'est à dire
éric sadin au fond vous voudriez qu'on
arrête de se soumettre à la norme qui
nous est imposée d'en haut mais au fond
laquelle nous contribuerons
en étant pressé on ne t'en les gens mais
comment ce comment cesser de se
soumettre à cette norme dans
généralement les gens font grève ou
alors ils manifestent musée l'air de
dire que ça sert à rien effectivement
d'après ce qui s'est passé au cours des
25 dernières années a pas servi à grand
chose alors comment je pense que nous
nous avons un peu négligé la capacité à
nous mobiliser pour des valeurs
fondamentales c'est à dire que nous
savons nous dressait c'est normal dès
qu'il s'agit du pouvoir d'achat par la
manifestation que des pertes d'emplois
sont sont en jeu je pense que pour des
dimensions fondamentales c'est à dire
que dès que dès que la dignité humaine
intégrité et que nous avons affaire à
une négation de soi de nous mêmes les
gilet jaune c'était un peu ça s'est
tellement il est là les tout débuts
après ils ont des gains ils ont défilé
pendant huit mois contre les violences
policières c'est qu'au départ il avait
des revendications c'était en partie
cela mais ça avait lieu dans la rue
moi je crois qu'il faut théorisé la rue
c'est à dire je crois qu'il faut savoir
nous nous mobiliser nous lever nous
élever la hawks a lieu je vous donne un
exemple
en 2015 14 françois hollande dans une
allocution fin dans un entretien
télévisé
avait il dit
à partir de la classe de cinquième
personne n'était au courant à partir de
la classe de 5e tous les collégiens à
partir de l'année prochaine rentrée 2015
vont étudier principalement par des
tablettes numériques
pourquoi étudier tous analyser tout ça
je n'ai absolument pas au courant
j'appelle des amis à l'inspection
professeur je visite il au courant vous
êtes au courant personne n'était au
courant donc aucune étude d'impact
qu'est-ce que c'était cela c'était du
résultat de lobbing c'était le résultat
de cette idéologie de la transformation
numérique digital de toute la société
et qu aurait pu corps et il pu se passer
si les professeurs avaient été
manifestée qu'est ce qui se serait passé
moi j'ai écrit une tribune dans
libération on m'a dit eric sadin
rétrograde il revenir à la bougie no no
nano parvient à la bougie qu'en est il
des livres scolaires qu'en est il de la
place du professeur quand tu n'utilises
et tablettes continuellement qu'en
est-il de l'immixtion de plateformes
privées dans l'éducation nationale c'est
toute une série d'enjeux auxquels on
serait aveugle si on les voyait pas de
près donc moi je vous avais fait dans
libération récemment contre le métavers
ce2 par exemple de facebook par exemple
mais par exemple je dis c'est la russie
avait été manifestée bon ouais peut-être
qu'on aurait eu sais pas combien de
pourcentage de professeurs certains dans
les rangs joueurs et 10 et des ringards
mais si dans le lycée s'étaient
organisés dans les écoles à l'échelle
nationale à dire il ya aucune
concertation quelle va être notre place
dans quelle mesure ça prend en compte
quantité de dimension ça ne se serait
pas passé comme ça mais par une ironie
de l'histoire comme quoi les choses ont
parfois cette idéologie va trop vite
toutes les tablettes aujourd'hui elles
sont dans les caves des conseils
généraux que je puisse télé puisque
c'étaient des collèges donc savoir nous
mobiliser mais je reviens je vous
promets que c'est la dernière fois mais
pour l'hôpital public je pense qu'il y a
par exemple du personal de la part du
personnel il ya eu un manque
d'organisation stratégique gisait dans
le marais la plupart sont démissionner
depuis c'est bien pour ça qu'il est
arrivant au manque de lits c'est à dire
qu'ils ont plus là absolument mais c'est
à dire nous organiser stratégiquement là
où j'évolue au quotidien dans le monde
du travail dans le monde des
institutions c'est une dimension
comprenez là on n'est pas dans leur sol
on est dans des actions politiques
ancrées qui suppose de l'organisation
qui suppose aussi de tenir à des à des
dimensions fondamentales qu'ont d'écran
société mais vous parlez de
réappropriation c'est se réapproprier
quoi alors moi je crois surtout que
serait appropriée c'est se donner les
moyens de répondre davantage à nos
aspirations alors là je sais c'est tout
un pan de mon livre sur lequel je
j'expose cela ce que nous avons exposé
la mettre en critique les discours
savoir nous interposer lorsque nous
considérons que des valeurs
fondamentales sont bafoués savoir nous
interposer là où nous évoluons et ça
c'est déjà nous réapproprier notre
existence et savoir de rendre agissant
mais selon moi la noue selon moi
la double dimension de notre de la bonne
expression de notre condition politique
a les jambes parce qu'on vit est
inévitablement est indissociablement à
leurs lèvres deux dimensions c'est une
dimension de refus
de savoir-faire la dimension pasolinien
de dire non même camus dans l'étranger
jeu
quand ils dépassent une certaine nuiton
le signal jusqu'à avec nos corps où le
signal mais il ya aussi une autre
dimension s'est donnée corps une
dimension pleinement positive de donner
corps à nos aspirations vous parlez de
libérer la vie quotidienne je sais pas
si j'utilise cette expression mais le
rendu
de libération de la vie quotidienne en
tous les cas de ceux du je pense que si
jamais autant qu'aujourd'hui il y a au
quotidien massivement à l'échelle de la
planète
l'envi de s'investir dans des pratiques
qui en tous points sur un virtuose mais
mais est-ce que ça ça me fait penser à
la table la photo vous avez montré tout
à l'heure est-ce que c'est pas le même
s'adonnant à la permaculture dans une
zad
en
vivant en communauté en chantant des
chansons alors c'est pas du tout comme
dans ses perspectives le signal
concernant la date j'ai écrit un
chapitre que j'ai appelée petite théorie
critique de la zad parce que je pique
que
très très précis et qui expose certains
enjeux de ce qui se joue dans la zad
c'est cette double dimension c'est à
dire des corps des consciences qui
s'élèvent en vue de
de faire front à des des décisions qui
semblent inique insère dans le bocage
d'installer à blood notamment celle de
la notre dame des landes a fait la une
aéroport de d'encourager cette logique
de surconsommation de transport aérien
et donc yann là on n'est pas dans la
manifestation dans la rue de savoir les
saveurs se mobiliser fait effet record 1
faire front avec son corps et en même
temps à la suite presque d'une façon
conséquente ce a rendu possible la mise
en oeuvre de deux modes de vie de mode
d'organisation
plus qu'ils répondent plus aux
aspirations qui relève de
l'expérimentation qui relève de l'entrée
en jeu du risque aussi un de l'aventuré
mais qui au fond réponde aux aspirations
mais est ce que ce ne sont pas des
simulacres comme là on voit des
simulacres de voyage ou où on pourrait
montrer des simulacres de liberté à la
plage
des milliers de gens à la plage ou
d'autres simulacre de liberté donc vous
évoquez aussi l'envié d'aller faire tous
du du parapente ou ou du ski pour pour
ce qui est du de ce que vous évoquez du
tourisme on peut lui dire c'est vrai
qu'elle a tout c'est toutes ces
pratiques la relève d'une sorte de près
ce qu'on a envie dire d'une dimension
cathartique un deuxième à la cantonne
les gens sont par milliers mais quand on
est tout seul ça marche oui mais en tout
cas à ce que six jeux cij et si je
disais petit théorie critique de la zad
c'est que l'enjeu c'est que ça reste
quand même cloisonné à la zad cloisonné
à un champ à ya des personnes alors que
ses aspirations là elles sont de plus en
plus partagée c'est pour ça que je
montrais vous m'avez demandé de choisir
une image que j'avais choisi celle ci
est donc je me suis dit j'ai beaucoup
voilà un peu mis les choses à plat
concernant cette question vous avez
remarqué frédéric relativement à la
désorientation de l'époque aux
difficultés de l'époque aujourd'hui il
ya une grande idée qui s'est imposée en
fait une grande idée pour moi c'est pas
une grande idée mais une idée qui s'est
imposé comme relevant de soi depuis
quelques années c'est le revenu de base
de revenu universel moi je ne suis pas
du tout que cette cette position
pourquoi parce qu'elle ne fera que
entériné des situations en cours
offrir des petites subsides
complémentaire aux personnes déjà en
souffrance qui vont soit cumuler les
emplois précaires ou alors transformé la
plupart d'entre nous en en éternel
pêcheurs à la ligne ou peintres du
dimanche c'est pas un projet de société
très très très très épanouissant et très
très enviable il me semble en revanche
que la collectivité
la société
apporte du soutien public des fonds
publics pour la mise en place de
collectif dans tous les champs de la vie
pas seulement dans la permaculture parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous remarquerez quand on
a envie de s'adonner à des pratiques
vertueuses on va dans la permaculture
qui n'a pas entendu aujourd'hui d'un
cousin d'un neveu d'un nom qui à tout
arrêter du jour au lendemain à ses
risques et périls
pour aller dans la creuse donc vous
voudriez que ce soit plus à ses risques
et périls qu'on l'aide qu'on
subventionne et que ça soit pas que pour
la permaculture dans tous les champs de
la vie là aujourd'hui nous sommes nous
vivons une robotisation de chasselas nos
régiments de nos conduits dans le monde
du travail vous voyez le mais c'est ça
que vous appelez le re le collectif
parce que vous appelez aussi à
hofouf dit que ce dont on s'est aperçu
avec la pandémie c'est que c'est qu'au
fond on vivait avec un individualisme
exacerbé que on avait besoin de deux
collectifs qu'on avait besoin d'une
société des mythes y est absolument
c'est à dire que je vais développer
cette notion dans mon livre que je nomme
institutionnalisée l'alternatif yann
oxymore un oxymore apparemment est bien
c'est que toutes les envies de
l'alternatif d'autres choses
d'expérimentation de risque tiens j'ai
envie de monter un atelier d'artisanat
d'ébénisterie de très grande qualité
avec quelques amis
comment je fais j'ai pas les moyens ou
alors voilà je mets un an voir un côté
avec cède 1,6 si l'état doit
subventionner tout les toutes les
fantaisies tous les fantasmes
le revenu de base
ils en veulent pas non plus mais c'est
vrai qu'ils aient de l'argent public
pour toutes les initiatives virtuel sur
un cahier des charges très simples
rapports équitable entre les êtres
pratiques qui favorisent
l'épanouissement et la crédulité de
chacun et qui ne laisse pas la biosphère
et sur trois ans on tente le coup aie
aie aie aie aie en plus qui ne laisse
pas la biosphère c'est à dire on serait
très très loin là on est dans un ancrage
du souci écologique on est très loin de
la cacophonie des discours actuellement
relativement à la crise et écologie et
moi je pense que parce que ça ne suffit
pas de dire tout est lié comment donne
t'on encore à cette formule aujourd'hui
on dit que souci écologique souci social
enjeu politique tout est lié certes mais
il faut bien donner un ancrage concret à
cela et moi je crois que c'est en
faisant essaimé en donnant les moyens à
un foisonnement de collectif dans tous
les champs de la vie dans le soin dans
l'éducation dans le l'artisanat dans la
production qui est quantité de deux
modalités alternatives dont on ne sait
peut-être absolument rien aujourd'hui
mais qu'ils soient soutenus est ce que
vous imaginez
l'autre paysage qui est à même de
d'émerger mais je ne dis pas du tout
cela dans une sorte de vision utopique
au contraire on a un nom mon souci est
de donner un ancrage à nos aspirations
et si on les bloque ses aspirations si
on consolide notre sentiment si on
consolide le sentiment d'inutilité de
soi d'invisibilité sociale ce qui était
un des enjeux majeurs de gilet jaune je
pense que nous allons vers des périls de
plus en plus aiguës et l'enjeu c'est de
donner corps à quoi à nos désirs à nos
aspirations et à notre capacité à être
davantage acteur de nous-mêmes agissant
dans ce monde ont l'impression d'être
dessaisi de nous mêmes individuellement
et collectivement
si ça c'est pas des enjeux politiques
majeurs qui nous regardent je ne sais
pas ce qui relève du politique
aujourd'hui en cette période de crise si
aigu de notre faire sécession c'est le
titre du nouvel essai d eric sadin qui
vient de paraître aux éditions de
l'échappée on fait une pause on se
retrouve cécile b on fonce au xviiie
siècle
[Musique]
ces cyber livre de l'historienne et vous
publié chez passé composé la légèreté et
le graver une histoire du dix huitième
en dix tableaux uniquement des tableaux
français c'est le dix huitième français
qui vous intéresse ou probablement parce
qu'il ya une légèreté une gravité à la
française et puis parce qu'on dit chante
le 18e et le siècle français aussi bien
sûr alors commençons par le premier
tableau vous avez choisi celui qui ouvre
le siècle pour vous c'est le pèlerinage
à 6 ter d'antoine bateau il a été pas en
1717 donc deux ans après la mort de
louis xiv on est sous la régence et
pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi celui-ci
m'a parce que pour moi c'est même ce
tableau qui quelque part va donner
l'acte de naissance au 18e c'est à dire
que même si on est évidemment déjà en
pleine régence pour moi bateau là il va
quelque part dessiner peindre bien sûr
mais aussi donner l'esthétique un peu le
la de tout un siècle en donnant
naissance à la fête galante oui c'est
une fête galante ça tu sais jamais où il
ya des hommes des femmes
et on sent bien qu est ce qu on appelle
une secte c'est une fête galante
d'ailleurs qu'on va appeler but plus
tard la fête galante à l'époque on
l'appelle ça comment ah bah en fait on
sait pas trop comment le nommer ouais
c'est ça qui est aussi très intéressant
et c'est aussi pour ça que quelque part
c'est aussi l'acte de naissance du
xviiie parce que là les hommes qui ont
été confrontés à ce chef-d'oeuvre ne
savait pas comment le nommer donc on
parle de fêtes galantes on parle de
scènes galantes ce qui est très
intéressant et alors là pour moi si on
rentre dans toute la tonalité du 18e
c'est qu'on ne sait pas véritablement ce
que l'on voit c'est le il faut bien voir
que c'est le contraire de ce qu'on a vu
pour longtemps c'est à dire la peinture
d'histoire ou l'app la thur religieuse
alors exactement le contraire c'est
exactement le contraire c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a rien qui se veut monumental
n'y a rien de grandiloquent et alors
surtout on ne sait pas si cette ces
couples ainsi ils reviennent d'un
pèlerinage situé à lille de l'amour ou
si au contraire ils vont s'embarquer est
en fait dans toute l'histoire de la
peinture dans toute l'histoire visuelle
mais pas seulement c'est probablement
une des caractéristiques majeures de
toulouse siem siècle on ne s'est jamais
véritablement est ce qu on est dans
quelque chose de plutôt léger ou dans au
contraire quelque chose qui est plutôt
grave qui a une forme de solidité du
monde il ya autre chose qui est déjà
dans ce tableau et qui va être là
pendant tout le xviiie siècle et
peut-être pour la première fois de façon
omniprésente c'est l'idée de liberté ya
de la liberté là bas il n'y a que de la
liberté s'il y a un mot clé pour le
xviiie siècle c'est évidemment le mot de
liberté est bien évidemment pas
justement comme on ne sait pas
véritablement ce que font ces couples où
ces groupes c'est aussi une façon
évidemment de manifester c'est un
premier manifeste de la liberté aux
xviiie et de labour parce que ça respire
l'amour comme un ca a fait plus que
respirer l'amour ça transpire sensualité
bien évidemment à cette liberté au 18e
on aurait tendance un peu à la résumer
pour pas dire à la réduire à cette
liberté sexuelle n'oublions pas que le
libertinage et en particulier 18e c'est
avant tout le fait de penser librement
et penser librement au 18e ce en dehors
de tout carcan institutionnel et en
premier lieu religieux c'est à dire de
pensée pour le dire simplement en dehors
de l'église chrétienne catholique
il ya quand même quelque chose aussi
dans ce tableau c'est que là il ya aucun
caractère de gravité c'est à dire qu'on
va la voir la gravité arriver mais là
vous la voyez déjà il ya quand même ce
tronc d'arbre à moitié mort mort au
promis voilà encore une fois d'être à
gauche voilà là mais il est à gauche
mais en tout cas elle est au premier
plan et on voit bien quand même qu' il
ya une forme de gravité il ya en tout
cas il ya quelque chose même dans la
végétation dans ces nuages
dans ce brouillard il ya quelque chose
qui plane sur sûr c'est alors passons le
deuxième tableau il est très célèbre
celle d'alice brune de françois boucher
il date de 1745 là on est soumis 15
françois boucher c'est la star c'est le
peintre faut bien comprendre que
l'époque les seules images dont on
dispose pour regarder le monde ce sont
les tableaux et les gravures qui en sont
tirés qui circulent
chez les gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'avoir des pelles tableau mais ce sont
les seules images dont on dispose donc
il faut voir l'importance que cela peut
avoir et pourquoi il ya tant de monde
qui va au salon
chaque année le délice que brune vous
dites c'est totalement pornographiques
cettex et l'arrivée de la pornographie
c'est la naissance de la pornographie de
la pornographie tels que nous presque
aujourd'hui on pourrait l'entendre bon
évidemment le mot n'est pas de moi c'est
une invitation à la sodomie c'est très
clair alors il ne serait ce que parce
que au centre du tableau exactement à
l'endroit des fesses de cette jeune
femme il ya y oui très bien et qui est
pile c'est y aller comme une cible c'est
là que c'est intéressant nous dit on et
c'est là que c'est intéressant il ya
plusieurs d'action boucher a atteint
plusieurs versions alors attention ces
peintures là elle n'était pas destinée à
être vue un vous dire que c'est pareil
c'est qu'on voit quelque chose nous on
comprend tout de suite mais ses
peintures là n'était pas du tout destiné
à être vu en même temps vous vous faites
remarquer que les pas non plus décidé de
cacher elle est signée françois boucher
l'acide et il en est très fier il en est
très fier il en a fait plusieurs actions
et elle va faire scandale donc elle va
évidemment faire scandale donc c'était
un rêve c'est quelque chose qui est
censé être interdit et interlope non
visibles et qui au final va bénéficier
d'une notoriété d'un scandale
inimaginable alors il faut voir qu'on
est en pleine mode des arts m2 hadoken
une note orientaliste mais il ya aussi
c'est ce qui choque beaucoup diderot le
père de lentilles etc l'eau bénite qui
ce qui donne son avis sur les pâtures
c'est que s'est sans doute la femme de
françois boucher qui pose ce qui est
complètement faux ah bon et c'était
aussi une façon évidemment de
décridibiliser françois boucher qui a un
peintre qui en son temps a été le
peintre le plus important est aussi le
plus riche qui a perdu aussi un peu de
sa superbe au fur et à mesure de son de
son de son travail artistique
en fait ce qu'on va lui reprocher
candide rôle attaque sur la légèreté de
sa femme c'est évidemment pour atteindre
la dignité de la commission que ça
dépasse robe à 2 parce qu'en fait on
arrête on a un certain nombre de sources
ou ont très clairement les recoupant on
constate très clairement que de la part
de diderot c'était un propos de l'ordre
de la diffamation mais diderot comme
beaucoup beaucoup de philosophes adoré
la diffamation est adorée de dire du mal
et diderot et là c'est un puritain
austère épouvantable on peut bien dire
aussi des autos et tout en étant un
grand libertin
alors viendra didot parce que là on va
voir des tableaux qu'il est
le
le portrait en pied de balades de popeye
duo de maurice quentin de la tour on
pourrait dire que celle inverse 1 c'est
la femme qui se redresse c'est la même
femme en pied c'est la femme debout et
puis surtout c'est la femme de pouvoir
c'est pas la femme qui attend d'être
prises comme bon marché au tableau de
boucher s'est dit en même temps il prend
du plaisir parce que c'est aussi ça qui
était dans le tableau précédent là c'est
la femme qu'ils restent c'est la femme
qui a du pouvoir et qui n'est plus la
maîtresse de louis 15 la maîtresse
physique mais qui est en revanche
favorite sait déjà que dans la
hiérarchie du pouvoir elle sait on peut
le dire que c'est presque un portrait
royal oui alors qu'elle n'est que
favorites royales si j'ose dire et
pompadour dont le peintre attitré était
justement françois boucher a été très
clairement tout au long du règne de
loups 15 la femme la plus importante de
france et là on a une représentation
presque officiel royal de ce qu'était le
pouvoir à la pompadour et il ya une
chose importante en ce qui la concerne
c'est que c'est la première favorite
royal qui souhaite une roturière oui
elle s'appelle poisson appel poisson
c'est une ascension sociale absolument
fulgurante et si aussi une femme qui
avait quand même une intelligence
absolument remarquable c'est pas
seulement une femme de réseaux mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui avait une
forme d'intelligence politique
incontestablement pour moi c'est même la
première femme politique est en tout cas
en france enfin en a eu d'autres
ailleurs mais et qui aurait nié l mais
en france c'est spécial il faut ajouter
que c'est un pastel c'est un pastel
alors c'est un pastel et c'est aussi une
oeuvre c'est d'autant plus important de
le souligner que les dimensions de ce
pastel sont tout à fait monumentale et
donc c'est d'autant plus un
chef-d'oeuvre parce qu'en terme de
difficultés techniques réussir une
oeuvre aux dimensions très grande part
la technique du pastel c'est explique
aussi le temps de réalisation c'est à
dire quasiment quatre années pour
réaliser ce jeu très pénible pour elle
pour elle et puis aussi parce que le le
portraitiste avait un caractère bien
trempé et chez une star un maurice
quentin de la tour le portraitiste star
il se conduit comme une star y compris à
la cour de versailles et
tableau suivant la corde et du village
de jean-baptiste greuze on attend 10 761
toujours sous le règne de louis 15 hélas
alors là un tableau qui va avoir un
immense succès au salon diderot val
acclamé pour lui c'est de la peinture
édifiante puisque
greuze à pain avec la solidité d'une
scène l'histoire justement là une scène
de la vie quotidienne donc une scène de
genre c'est l'histoire d'un d'un paysan
qui donne sa fille à son gendre legendre
et au milieu de deux bouts il a une main
dans une main il a l'argent de la dot
dans l'autre main la main de sa fiancée
et c'est toute une histoire qui se
raconte il suffit de regarder les
personnages les uns à côtés des uns
après les autres et on sait tous ce qui
se passe dans la tête de chacun
et pour cause parce que c'est avant tout
c'est une peinture du sentiment et de la
sensibilité du moins telle qu'elle
existe au milieu du xviiie siècle alors
avec en revanche avec nos sensibilités
d'aujourd'hui c'est assez difficile de
la comprendre cette peinture parce que
cette peinture elle a été gravé
reproduite à l'envi on va dire quasiment
pendant toute la moitié de la deuxième
moitié du xviiie siècle c'est à dire que
dans les pubs même dans les habitations
modestes la cordée du village étaient
punaisé est aujourd'hui avec nos
sensibilités on a du mal à on a du mal
en fait accompli on voit bien le trouver
parce que regarder la mer qui a du mal à
se séparer de sa fille la soeur cadette
qui a du mal à séparer tout la new line
et ils y allaient l'aîné qui est
derrière le père qui elle est jalouse de
pas être l'accord des deux de la journée
mais si on regarde attentivement la
finance il ya quand même une sensualité
fortes qui sont des gages aussi et donc
en fait il a les hits entre ses parents
ils sont mon site alors entre ses
parents son futur époux la vie familiale
et aussi la vie sensuelle charnel est ce
ce tableau il est c est là où il est
important c'est qu'on voit le peuple
aussi alors c'est une scène paysanne le
18e raffole des scènes d'intérieur des
scènes de joie et des scènes de la vie
paysanne même si elle est très idéalisée
d'abord si on regarde attentivement
cette scène c'est un intérieur très
propre je ne dirais pas raffiné mais
qu'à une casse etc ok donc c'est le 18e
et en particulier les élites adore
idéaliser le paysage doublement à un
paysan qui est qui a bien réussi qui a
bien réussi c'est un paysan bourgeois
ont regardé battant le dire ou de
fragonard ans part en 1778 alors ça bon
fragonard c'est beaucoup mieux greuze en
tant que patron ya pas photo
vous voilà là on a affaire un virtuose
tableau extrêmement
cette botte alors là la légèreté on la
voit on a l'impression qu'ils dansent
alors il ya la légèreté en fait là il ya
autant de légèreté
dans le livre je mange je un peu
facilement je parle du grand basculement
parce que ce soit dans une histoire
longue du xviiie ou danse l'histoire
restreinte de sur cette toile évidemment
là encore on ne sait pas ce qu'on voit
véritablement est-ce qu'on voit une
scène de non consentement est ce qu'on
voit une scène d'amour consentie ou à
jouer le verrou après tout est-ce qu'il
les protège de l'intérieur ou de
l'extérieur
et ce qu'il veut en faire ou est ce
qu'il est ce qui ferme la porte pour pas
qu'ils soient dérangés on ne sait pas ce
qui est certain c'est que ça renvoie en
tout cas pour moi ça renvoie largement
une partie de la culture libertines ou
xviiie où il faut dire les choses le
viol fait partie de la culture
libertines par pas seulement parmi les
élites mais y compris dans le milieu de
de la bourgeoisie ou le viol fait partie
et bien des moeurs et la gravité là on
le voit la gravité c'est le lit qui est
à la fois basse et le lycée le sexe mais
c'est aussi un sexe féminin c'est alors
le moelleux des coussins les draperies
alors il ya aussi d'ailleurs ça de la
part de fragonard qui avait un caractère
pas possible il ya aussi la volonté de
montrer à quel point il est bien plus
académique que c'est que ses collègues
académiciens
lui qui ne veut surtout pas être
académique donc il ya aussi un défi
pictural et pour montrer à quel point
les biens il est bien meilleur que les
autres et je pense sincèrement qu'il
était de son temps on fragonard au 18e
c'est le peintre absolue c'est c'est le
pain c'est le picasso le matisse du 18e
c'est bien évident
et alors là bon c'est très très beau
tableau il ya peut être du mal à s'en
séparer on a du mal à s'en séparer mais
on a du mal à s'en séparer parce que si
on n'arrive pas à trancher ouais voilà
comme on n'arrive pas à trancher comme
on sait pas exactement dans quel
registre on se situe et il ya aussi une
forme de fascination
qui peut être pas très saine je ne sais
pas mais il ya tellement d'éléments à
comprendre et à rattacher les uns aux
autres voilà on ne sait pas on ne sera
jamais marie antoinette à la rose
elisabeth vigée-lebrun
1783 donc un tableau
qui est là pour ans pour éteindre un
scandale c'est à dire que juste avant il
d'isabelle viger le goff brun a peint
marie antoinette des rochers pas si on
l'a normalement la ona marie antoinette
en
en robe en goule comme on appelait ça à
l'époque c'est à dire en mousseline
voilà voilà le tableau qui fait scandale
parce qu'elle est presque nulle pour les
spolier les codes de l'époque elle est
nue on en 1783 c'est une vraie
révolution avant la révolution est donc
pour faire taire le scandale parce qu'on
accuse marc antoine est de poser nue
d'être vêtu comme une femme de chambre
fin de papa qui y ait de quoi farid ce
naturel est considérée absolument comme
indécents pour ne pas dire scandaleux
donc la fin le louis saez réagi demande
de retirer ce tableau tableau que
marie-antoinette adorait que vigée
lebrun ne pouvait cadore parce qu'elle
en a peint des dizaines et des faits
sont sentis balas et son style donc elle
l a fait si j'ose dire ce qu'on lui a
demandé de faire et donc on va retirer
marie-antoinette danse portant cette
robe dit en gaule pour 7 mario de marie
antoinette à la rose que et vigée lebrun
et marie antoinette des tests et dont
nous nous sommes absolument rassasié que
nous détestons même en demeurant s'il ya
malheureusement une image dans notre vie
quotidienne au 21ème siècle encore nous
voyons du xviiie un peu partout c'est
évidemment marie antoinette à la rose et
1d fragonard donc cette marie antoinette
à la rose détesté du modèle détesté de
l'artiste et qui est pourtant l'image
officielle de celle qui est devenue
aujourd'hui une icône qui vous avez
consacré plusieurs livres
rares et il est assez drôle comme ça
tranche avec le tableau suivant qui est
le serment des horaces qui est pas à la
même époque pratiquement la même année
je crois que quelques mois plus tard
jacques louis david qui avec ce retour à
l'antiquité à la sévérité de l'antique
même créé un nouveau courant le
néoclassicisme alors il crée un nouveau
courant qui évidemment très très sérieux
très bonne mentalité à aller puiser dans
les tests dans les textes pardon de
l'antiquité et qui va essayer aussi de
créer une nouvelle manière donc c'est le
retour de l'antiquité mais une antiquité
évidemment qui
relu recréé avec des sensibilités celle
du xviiie et qui va évidemment faire
fureur dans les années précédant la
révolution et surtout surtout sous la
révolution il ya une raideur il ya une
morale il ya une vertu je crois que
diderot est mort mais il aurait adoré
alors il aurait probablement adoré
décidément vous êtes très dur avec
diderot il aurait adoré alors il y en a
beaucoup qui ont adoré il y en a aussi
beaucoup qui ont été un peu accablée
parce que là on rentre évidemment si
j'ose dire non du lourd dans quelque
chose de très grave dans une seule unité
qui est de plus en plus
oui grave monumentale et qui laissent de
moins en moins de place pour la
sensibilité
qui se fait de plus en plus morale de
plus en plus grande les eaux près bien
mais c'est aussi ça qui m'a intéressé
dans votre livre on voit bien que nous
même à notre époque on a vécu un passage
comme ça on est passé d'une légèreté à
une gravité actuelle à un moralisme et
on l'a vécu mais je pense qu'on
l'histoire peut-être souvent un grand
recommence forme et qui effectivement la
légèreté le grave qui a été écrit
pendant un confinement
je me suis évidemment j'ai ces
sentiments-là je les ai moi-même
éprouvée nous les avons tous éprouvé ces
derniers mois on va regarder l'auto
portrait d'elisabeth vigée lebrun qui
fait suite qu'elle peint en 1789 dans
les tous premiers mois de la révolution
juste avant que marie antoinette et
louis saez ne soit enlevé je les dires
de versailles pour revenir à paris
quitte le château de versailles à ce
moment-là vigée le brun va partir en
exil en italie elle va faire une immense
carrière dans toutes les capitales
d'europe c'était déjà la portraitiste la
plus à la mode est la mieux payée je
crois que peu de son temps elle était
membre de l'académie où il y avait des
femmes c'est la révolution qu'il
retirera les femmes de l'académie la
russie trader
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que du bon dans la
révolution française mais ce tableau il
est très important ne serait ce que
parce qu'elle est elle-même habillant de
mousseline et c'est aussi parce qu'elle
même elle elle représente le versant
féminin du néoclassicisme et de
l'antiquité de l'antiquité c'était qu'on
parle toujours du néoclassicisme en
parlant de david et de ses élèves faut
pas oublier que davie lui-même a eu des
élèves femme et que vigée-lebrun bien
c'est le néoclassicisme et à la
française et au féminin est bon depuis
quelques années depuis au moins 2015 on
josy on réhabilite vigée lebrun pour moi
c'est c'est l'un des plus grands
peintres du xviiie siècle et c'est une
femme et c'était une femme et et alors
ce qui est encore plus important et
c'est une royaliste qui était d'un point
de vue strictement politique très très
conservatrices donc c'est ça qui est
aussi intéressant c'est qu'on peut être
au point on peut être une avant-gardiste
en tant qu'artiste et très réactionnaire
d'un point de vue strictement politique
est très avant gardiste du point de vue
de la mode puisque la telle qu elle est
habillée joséphine de beauharnais sabira
comme ça avec les saints quasiment à
l'air dans les soirées mondaines
quelques années plus tard en lycée
lebrun est incontournable dans
l'histoire de la mode au 18e et même en
partie aux 19e et il faut pas oublier
que les femmes sont quasiment dévêtue
sous directoire le haut
alba oui
le tableau suivant c'est la mort de
marat de david encore david et alors là
là on est là on est dans la pâture de
propagande on est dans la gravité total
on est
vous dites carrément c'est la mort du
xviiie siècle alors là très clairement
c'est la mort du xviiie siècle c'est pas
qu'une facilité de ma part parce qu'on a
un mourant dans une baignoire mais c'est
aussi parce que après à mon sens après
ce tableau la de david on va basculer
dans d'autres sensibilités qui ne sont
plus proprement 18e mais dans un 19ème
siècle avant la lettre alors là bien sûr
c'est une oeuvre de propagande politique
s'il en est
ce corps christique qui était
extrêmement malade mais qui paraît si
beau si jeune si pure et qui meurt d'un
coup de poignard bien évidemment on ne
voit pas l'assassin qui est une femme
l'a vraiment charleroi on ne voit
qu'elle et j'ai le temps quelque part et
quand j'étais enfant et que je voyais ce
tableau pour m'envoyer qu'elle faut pas
oublier qu'elle a 25 ans charlotte
corday zac talent et d'un courage
extraordinaire elle agit seul contraire
de ce que tout ce qui doit essayer de
montrer elle était seule c'est pas du
tout une royaliste elton exalté voilà
elle elle tue 1 elle tue quelqu'un qui
lui semble monstrueux monstrueux et le
tue avec beaucoup de courage comme elle
montera à l'échafaud avec beaucoup de
courage aussi avec un sang-froid qui est
même assez redoutable et qui sera
analysée à l'époque comme une
manifestation de l'hystérie féminine
voilà c'est ça mais ce tableau il est
alors il fonctionne il est il y a des
copies partout à l'époque on défile dans
la rue avec ce tableau de ce tableau de
david et c'est david quoi c'est horrible
c'est parce qu'ils avaient des habitudes
et quand je dis ça c'est pas une
méchanceté à son égard il avait aussi
des habitudes commerciales donc quand on
ne commande une heure de san roque pas
de barre en plus
de robespierre puis un jour d'un certain
bonaparte il va il va produire un
certain nombre de copies avec certaines
nuances à l'intérieur de son atelier et
c'est aussi parce qu'on a une époque où
on sacralise alors ça c'est pour moi
c'est aussi une façon de clore ce 18e
par le sont pas seulement avec le son
qui est répandu sous la révolution quand
on travaille sur un dix huitième l'on
s'aperçoit que le sang est omniprésent
dans la culture et dans l'image maire du
18e mais je voudrais un terreau parce
que j'aimerais qu'on revoie le
l'embarquement pour cythère ce qui est
le titre qu'on lui avait donné au départ
parce qu'on était au début du xviiie là
on est à la fin du xviiie et on pourrait
se dire des tableaux comme celui là
peut-être qu'on avait au début du 18e au
même moment où vato penyes iter
peut-être que d'autres payaient débarras
assassinés dans leur baignoire mais non
en fait non un tableau comme celui là il
est inimaginable de le faire au début un
siècle plus tôt alors il est
inimaginable dans deux le faible d'une
personnalité politique mais après bon on
voit bien qu'il ya quand même la geste
c'est une peinture religieuse il
récupère toute sa culture religieuse
pour en faire une peinture politique
mais ça va sans dire qu'effectivement au
début du xviiie siècle on ne va
certainement pas à les représenter un
mourant connu dans sa boîte baignoire
agonisant oui et correspond aussi à
l'affirmation de l'individu et et des
tableaux comme celui ci comme celui dont
le bateau on n'en fait plus et
ayant d'air pour être honnête on en fait
plus de à la fin du xviiie ça fait au
moins deux décennies que la fête galante
et à son tour est morte c'est là qu'il
ya évidemment il ya des va et vient dans
la peinture entre une légèreté une
gravité pied aussi des modes faut pas
oublier que la peinture c'est un art et
c'est aussi des réseaux commerciaux donc
il ya des modes les modèles se démode
elles sont faites même pour être un jour
démodé donc effectivement c'est fait là
elles vont mourir d'ailleurs avec
fragonard les dernières fêtes galantes
c'est la fin des années 1770 dernier
tableau le dixième que vous avez choisi
c'est le portrait de bas de laine de
mariga les mines benoît id est de 1800
donc la dernière année du 19e du xviiie
siècle
l époque on l'appelait le portrait d'une
négresse maintenant on a retrouvé qui n
était madeleine qui était une domestique
on est six ans sept ans après oui six
ans après l'abolition de l'esclavagé
est donc une femme libre et qui est
peinte comme une femme de la haute
société
comme une femme très belle déjà avant
tout un très bel qui a évidemment une
forte sensualité qui a c'est peut-être
pas évident mais qui est quand même à
billet un peu aux couleurs tricolores
blanc du rouge d'il ya du bleu sur le
fauteuil et c'est évidemment
l'affirmation
d'une couleur de peau alors ne pas on a
souvent fait de cette femme peintre un
peul olympe de gouges la peinture pas du
tout ma rue guy les mines benoît voilà
qui a été entre autres élèves de david
alors elle elle est ultra ultra
royalistes elle est contre l'abolition
de l'esclavagé
par contre ceux qui la fascine c'est ce
défi que le fait de représenter une peau
noire sur la toit parce que l époque qui
ne savaient pas le faire ou avec grande
difficulté c'est un véritable défi
chromatique est là la femme peintre a
réussi à le faire et c'est vraiment un
des plus beaux chef-d'oeuvre conserver
considéré comme tel à l'époque de
considérer comme tel et et c'est avant
tout une poisse pour montrer sa grande
dextérité technique et c'est pas du tout
là pour le coup un manifeste politique
merci
je rappelle le titre de votre livre
cécile berly il s'intitule la légèreté
et le graver une histoire du xviiie en
tableau il est paru chez passé composé
merci avec sa d'un merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]